so what was your first big break in the
show business American Pie great
character thank you love that movie
thank you watch at least five times
American Pie is so good I was working at
Home Depot as a plumber I lived in La
for like three years and no kidding and
uh you came to LA to be an actor yeah
but I I didn't really know anything
about it it was one of the first
comedies ever audition for and I and I
sucked and then um I think I worked at
Scientific Revolution selling glow the
dark stars I worked at California Pizza
Kitchen as a host and and I didn't you
know I think it was getting better at
auditions I didn't have any credits and
then I was I was working as a car Pusher
did you have an agent yeah I got lucky
to get an agent right away but I had
audition for some bad stuff right away
and then and was it embarrassing to you
that you were getting no work and you
had this agent everyone was waiting for
you to get some work I don't think they
were even waiting you know I was just
like I don't know if they knew it was
going to happen but the year before I
got American Pie I started getting
better I thought I was getting better
and then um then I got the script for
American piie and I was like the the
Stiffler part was like two scenes long
and um I just knew I needed to get apart
and so I called up all these kids that I
went to school with and uh cuz I was you
know I was kind of a nice guy and I was
like I have to do something different
you know to get this part and I took I
called up all these guys and this one
guy was kind of a jerk to me but had
characteristics that I thought really
really interesting and I would just like
you know kind him a little bit yeah and
I went in I fooled him I got the
part